you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and going to do another
group of three puzzles and simply share
my thoughts along the way so in this
first one we're playing as white hurt
we're playing as black I'm off off to a
good start here okay this King is kind
of short on squares my feeling I must
say is that this initial check is not
correct because the King can run here
so I'm thinking about this move first
but now revisiting this again that helps
any kind of going back and forth these
to bring the candidate moves Queen a-one
and Bishop to b2 I am seeing what the
solution is to this one yeah this is a
mate puzzle and it does involve this
initial check on a1 with only then in
ensuing check on B for playing this move
first while it takes away this know
let's say run away square let's get rid
of the getting hit with the color scheme
gambit it's been a while but yeah that
gambit appears every now and then yeah
what I was going to say is if we play
Bishop before first this quiet defensive
move of d2 it gives white a an
opportunity to play c3 and have the C 2
square available for the King also worth
noting is that given a move for white
there is no good
checking move against the black King so
we're in no serious danger here is black
there may be these quiet moves available
to us because there is no great attack
against our King so I'm thinking that
after Queen a1 check King d2 we could
then play Bishop b4 and after c3 in this
case we can capture on c3 with our
bishop though with our Queen on a1 she
has some influence on c3 whether she's
on a 5 or a 1 she's trained on the c3
square right now directly once she's on
a1 she's has an indirect influence on c3
so I'm pretty sure this is a may puzzle
with Queen a1 King d2 Bishop b4 c3 only
move
Bishop takes pawn if King to see to we
would take on b2 with our queen and that
would be mate but this one is turning
out to be a ma in how many 1 2 3 4 5
Queen a 1 King d2 Bishop b4 c3 Bishop
takes pawn pawn takes Bishop Queen takes
on and actually that's already mate it's
a mate in 4 I was for some reason
thinking the king goes to C to R to the
back rank and then the rook comes down
here this is actually a million for so
let's put it on the board Queen a1 they
should be four
these are only replies by white and
after this capture here that's the ball
game
okay that's not a bad start let's try a
puzzle to team black let's get it right
this time
all right well I'm immediately drawn to
the square because there's a knight
check so we have some control of the
dark squares if we need it by our knight
controlling f2f for also seeing that the
Queen and King are on the same file so
the rook size might start to light up
some possibilities for forks or pins by
the rook additionally the Queen is a bit
short on squares you know she is
definitely short on squares here for
example if we play g6 she doesn't have
very many replies if she's going to well
she only has the g5 square mm you know
this feels like a puzzle that takes
advantage of a piece that is short on
squares some kind of Queen trap this
prawn is pinned that
how that's going to play a role but it's
really powerless it's not really
threatening the night right now I don't
think that this rook will be relevant to
this puzzle this bishop is unprotected
how are we looking from a material
standpoint we're up a pawn is black can
we take advantage of this unprotected
bishop the queen is also unprotected I'm
thinking it's more directed and this
puzzle is more directed at tackling this
white queen somehow suppose g6 gleen
here's the only safe Square how could we
take advantage of the Queen's position
there hmm it is a queen trap g6 Queen g5
and this is actually pretty tricky to
spot g6 Queen g5 f six attacking her
further Queen is defending that where
would she go from g5 these squares are
covered by the rook all these squares
covered she would have to go to h6 in
our last move of f6 is opening up a new
square for our Knight to play Knight f7
and the Queen is officially cooked g6
Queen g5 f six Queen h6 Knight f7 and
she's officially trapped yeah it must be
this must be it directed at the Queen I
didn't really see a way to take
advantage of the bishop moves like I
don't know Queen here setting up Brooke
to e2 or just to slow gives white to
gives white a moment to bring a new
piece involved or involve a new piece
develop a new piece rook to e1 summer up
to e1 but this is I'm pretty sure this
is it just double checking g6 Queen g5 f
six Queen h6 is the only save square and
then Knight to f7 is the idea
put it on the board that is correct and
yep it's solved from here so I believe
Queen here would not be best at this
stage but rather I don't know I guess
Queen here and you'd have a rook for
Queen exchange because Queen h6 you're
just going to get the Queen for a minor
piece or Queen h6 Knight f7 and then the
Queen goes back but yeah this is the
trick here Queen h6 night f7 and she's
trapped alright let's try one last one
not too bad he's first to team white
okay a little bit scary here our king is
cut off as white so you really need to
act fast
not quite threatening mate but you know
there are these checks and then we would
have to block with the rook hmm I think
it's just going to be this quiet move I
don't I'm not sure what more there would
be besides rook to h3 as a candidate
move to be perfectly honest I don't see
a way to improve the rook I don't see
what moving this Bishop would accomplish
rook to h3 is threatening a bishop move
with a discovered check mate and also
just the idea to move the bishop with
check and capture the rook rook to h3 if
a rook plays to c1 or D 1 we simply
block the check and give checkmate there
is no knight move with check yeah this
has to be it look to h3 also defends the
h2 school
if rook h3 and rook g2 we could just
relate to the corner I don't see
anything wrong with that if then Knight
to f2 we would take the rook because
rook on g2 knight on f2 there's a
disconnect between the rooks I don't see
what else it would be besides our up to
h3 in this one to be perfectly honest I
have no other candidate moves here to
even consider it must be it well let me
back up for just a moment and say that I
guess there is one other move to
consider and that is well questioning
the move order just a tad you know if
this is the idea with rook h3 and Bishop
g4 maybe but should excuse me rook h3
Bishop g5 for mate maybe going with this
move first is worth considering but I
don't like this because if Bishop g5
it's just not it's not throwing a strong
enough punch like there are these moves
of then rook to G to check rook takes h2
and then you know we're not even getting
to the h3 square so it's important that
we establish our rook on h3 first and
defend h2 we're not we're not allowing
black to take on h2 in control h3 and by
keeping the bishop on h4 we're preparing
to meet these first rank checks with a
bishop block so this must be it that is
correct and I'm almost certain we just
go straight to the corner yeah I
actually I didn't understand this
problem as well as I should before I
made that first move because I'm seeing
what the trick is going to be now not
Knight - f2 after king h1 but rather g5
and then the trick is going to be Bishop
f2 which is an interference
disconnecting the rooks and then we take
the rook
hmm maybe I should have thought a bit
more about where exactly to go with the
king because I guess this is also a fine
move as well King to f1 no no no no it
is important to go to h1 because King f1
they take the route they take on h2 so
we need to keep him defended and now
this is the key idea yeah I wouldn't
consider me solve I didn't see this one
correctly to its end I wouldn't I
wouldn't give myself full credit for
this because I should have seen that
this was the idea I I referenced this
Knight F to move and why it was not
working yet okay well they're going a
little further here I believe we just
scooped up this Knight and be content
with the material advantage you know we
could just take this Knight right now
there'd be anything better yeah I really
couldn't have anticipated this variation
that the computer is throwing at us
right now
I don't know is there any great
difference here and they're gonna grab
this rook if we move our King so why not
just grab this Knight I don't really see
what the big difference would being I'm
missing something I mean this is
simplest to just take the knight I
believe that that's what it would be
yeah that's the solution okay that one
wasn't too bad just recognizing up to h3
Bishop g5 that wasn't too difficult to
reason out why it was more important to
insert rook h3 first you needed to stop
black from potentially controlling the
h3 Square and this one okay not a bad
set of three this time around as usual
feel free to leave any feedback share
how you did with these three in the
comment section below and I'll catch you
in the next video that's all for now
take care bye